عرف طريقه الى الشاشه مبكرا واجتهد ليصبح
نجما سينمائيا تطارده عدسات الكاميرات فهو
ليس مجرد اسم في هوليود انه بن افليك
الممثل الناجح وكاتب السيناريو المبهر
والمخرج المبدع وكذلك المنتج الذي يريد ان
يحافظ على قيم الفن النبيله فما قصته ولد
بنجامين افليك عام
1972 بكاليفورنيا وبدات تمثيل وهو في
السابعه فقط حيث ظهر بفيلم ذا دارك اند
اوف ذا ستريت ثم واصل الطريق حيث جمعته
صداقه مبكره بماده يمين فاخذ كلاهما دروسا
في الدراما عان افليك بسبب انفصال والديه
عندما كان في الحاديه عشره فقط وانتقل
حينها الى ماساتشوست حيث تابع دراسته
الثانويه لكنه واصل الاعمال التلفزيونيه
واشتهر من خلال السلس التعليميه
درس افلك بكليه اوكسدنتال لكنه ترك
الدراسه بعد عام ليلتحق بجامعه التي تركها
ايضا بعد فصل واحد لمتابعه مسيرته المهنيه
حيث لعب ادوارا ثانويه بافلام مستقله مثل
قبل ان يشارك بفيلم الكوميديا مالرات
للمخرج كافين سميث الذي اختاره لبطوله
مسرحيه تشيسنج ايمي في عام
1992 تعاون افليك مع ديمن لكتابه سيناريو
فيلم جود وول هنتينغ الذي صدر بعد خمسه
اعوام واثر محاولات مضنيه انتهت ببيع
حقوقه لشركه ميرا ماكس فلقى الفيلم صدى
كبيرا واهلهما للفوز بجوائز كبرى مثل
جولدن جلوب والاوسكار بعد ذلك ظهر افليك
بفيلم الذي حقق نجاحا هائلا كما قام بدور
مساعد بفيلم
الذي كان سببا في ارتباطه بنجمه الفيلم
لكنهما انفصل بعدها كما عانى من ادمان
الكحول ما دفعه في عام 2001 لتسجيل نفسه
بمركز اعاده تاهيل لياخذ استراحه لم تضم
طويلا حيث ظهر بعد عام بسلسله افلام بوش
التلفزيونيه بعد الانفصال الاول تصدرت
علاقه افليك بالمغنيه جنيفر لوبيز عناوين
الاعلام لكنهما انفصل ايضا ليتزوجا
بالممثله جينيفر جارنر في عام 2005 وينجب
منها ابنا وابنتين لكنهما انفصل بعد 12
عاما كما استمرت معاناه افليك من ادمان
الكحول ودخل المصحه مجددا في عام 2017
و2008 وهو ما الهمه للابداع فيه ذ الذي
يمثل حياه مدرب كره سله مدمن على الكحول
قبل ان يعود الاهتمام الاعلام في العام
الماضي بسبب زواجه من جنيفر روبيز
ومشاركته لها بطوله فيلم
جمع افليك خلال مسيرته ثروه تقدر بنحو 150
مليون دولار وفي رصيده اليوم اكثر من 82
فيلما ناجحا كممثل مع تجارب ناجحه في
الاخراج وكتابه السيناريو لافلام عديده
لعل ابرزها فيلم ارغو الذي اهله للفوز
بجائزه جولدن جلوب والبافتا كذلك خاضع
تجارب في الانتاج كان اهمها قيامه مع
دايما بانتاج السلسله الوثائقيه
قبل ان يعلن عن منصه جديده للانتاج
السينمائي تحت اسم
فيما اعتبره محاوله للحفاظ على قيم الفن
ومبادئه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]